[Music]
lula is back
at 76 former president louisiana
says he's older wiser and ready to lead
a coalition of center-left parties to
victory in october's presidential
election
i want to tell you that i am willing to
govern brazil 12 years after leaving the
presidency and 12 years we learned a lot
we are able to see what we did for the
country what we did not do and what we
could have done a former car factory
worker lula governed brazil from 2003 to
2010.
as president he was one of the world's
most popular leaders
but after leaving office he was jailed
on corruption charges and barred from
running again
his political fate changed last year
when brazil's supreme court annulled his
trial
since then he has emerged as the most
formidable challenger to the incumbent
jair bolsonaro
i think that corruption is going to be
an issue
because
bolsonaro will make sure that he will
use
the
the the corruption scandal against ruler
but
i think that
after
the
almost four years of bolsonaro
and in
several cases of corruption his
government
this has not
this has changed it's not
it's not
in a weapon that will fire only on one
side
maggie fernandez voted for bolsonaro but
four years on she's disappointed
bolsonaro was elected promising to fight
corruption to reduce public spending and
to adopt business friendly economic
measures he did the opposite he is
wheeling and dealing to win support in
congress something he said he would
never do
there is corruption and the economy is
in shreds
rule is trying to appeal to disappointed
bolsonaro voters by choosing a former
adversary and center-right politician
geraldo alchemy as his vice president
he's also counting on anger at
bolsonaro's denial of the coven 19
pandemic which killed
660 000 brazilians
and his anti-environmental policies
recent polls show lula defeating
bolsonaro political analyst sasha
branchish says rejection more than
approval will play a major role in this
election
sixty percent of brazilians say they do
not approve of bolsonaro and would never
vote to re-elect him lula fares slightly
better with 45 percent of voters
rejecting his candidacy
it's still too soon to tell who will win
this race but most analysts agree that
brazilians will have to choose the
candidate they dislike less instead of
the one they believe represents them or
will make their future better monica
yanakiv al jazeera sao paulo